entonces hacía un llamado a ustedes para
que tuvieran el coraje de construir la
paz y hacer juntos nuestras
responsabilidades este coraje
se ha visto en un shock por el la crisis
sanitaria de seguridad de un impacto
global desde la creación de la esta
organización hace 75 años y ese coraje
fue primero el de aquellos que
estuvieron desde el primer día en
primera línea en todas partes del mundo
y que todavía lo están para curar nutrir
acompañar
no suele aguantar
es el personal humanitario y médico y
quiero comenzar desde estas palabras
pensando en ellos ellos esperan que nos
comprometamos y que construyamos con
respuestas concretas juntos
porque esta crisis sin duda más que
cualquier otra impone la cooperación
impone inventar nuevas soluciones
internacionales
creo en la ciencia en el conocimiento y
la humanidad va a vencer esta pandemia
pero mientras esperamos y no sabemos
cuánto va a durar cada uno de nuestros
países no tendrá otra opción que
aprender a vivir con el virus y el mundo
tendrá que aprender a vivir con esta
nueva realidad que se nos impone que
revelan nuestras vulnerabilidades nos
pone ante nuestras responsabilidades
inmediatas también esta nueva realidad
mundial es clara y brutal
y claramente vertiginosa y tenemos que
mirarla sin dejarnos caer en la
desesperanza tenemos que verlo con
lucidez y todos los desafíos a los
cuales nos enfrentamos en pocos meses
quedaron acentuado si agravados los
éxitos que hemos tenido
quedaron desdibujados años de progreso
contra otras enfermedades como la
tuberculosis o el sida o la malaria
han tomado retraso
a veces más más de 37 millones de
personas
cayeron o volvieron a caer en la pobreza
extrema pobreza extrema
en magnitud alimentaria también es una
grande también por el cierre de las
escuelas en decenas de países 40
millones de niños no pudieron
beneficiarse de su primer año de
educación las mujeres en primera línea
vieron cómo se acumulado en las formas
de violencia o apoyo les doméstica
sexual y ante esto y ante todas
consecuencias que ha dejado la pandemia
en el planeta y que continúa tocando a
todos los continentes la fracturación de
los medios colectivos se hace la única
solución vendrá de nuestra cooperación y
las organizaciones internacionales de
las que necesitamos como la organización
mundial de la salud fueron acusadas por
unos
e instrumentalizada por otros
los científicos que son tan necesarios
para comprender la crisis fueron puestos
en duda por propaganda estatal
como por la epidemia de la
desinformación nuestra organización en
sí misma se enfrentó al reto de la
impotencia el consejo de seguridad de
naciones unidas que es garante de la paz
y la estabilidad difícilmente pudo
entenderse en una tregua humanitaria que
nosotros apoyamos con toda nuestra
fuerza imaginen es tener tanta
dificultad para ponernos de acuerdo
sobre algo así pero los miembros
permanentes no pudieron en
circunstancias excepcionales reunirse
como les hemos querido porque dos de
ellos
prefirieron mostrar su rivalidad todas
las fracturas que estaban antes de la
pandemia
el choque hegemónico de las potencias la
duda sobre el multilateralismo
el pisoteo de los derechos se hicieron
más profundos y ayudaron a aumentar esta
situación no tenemos el derecho de
cerrar los ojos ya no tenemos la
oportunidad el lujo si puedo decir de
tergiversar esta pandemia debe ser para
nuestra organización el momento de
levantarnos y de abrir los ojos y es
posible porque en este momento hay
motivos de esperanza la unión europea de
la cual
muchos decían que era impotente y logró
un paso histórico de unidad de soberanía
de solidaridad de elección por el futuro
es la europa que por los socios
africanos tomó la
ayudo a los países africanos a
enfrentarse a la pandemia y quitarles un
poco de la deuda que pesaban sobre ellos
y que pone en peligro el futuro del
continente por primera vez en un g20
optamos por una moratoria sobre la deuda
de los países más pobres de áfrica no es
europa a europa que con sus socios pudo
construir
los medios de lucha contra la pandemia
para que sean accesibles a todos
asequibles
europa junto con otros permitió que la
asamblea mundial de la salud aprenda de
las lecciones de la pandemia y tenga
mejores sistemas de alerta precoz es y
europa gracias a otros socios en asia en
américa en áfrica tuvo la energía de
construir de proponer de encontrar
soluciones concretas de cooperación y de
solidaridad y de acción tendremos que
contar en el futuro con estos nuevos
equilibrios que se están definiendo
tendremos que contar sobre la fuerza de
la buena voluntad porque el mundo tal y
como está hoy no puede resumirse a una
rivalidad entre eeuu y china sin
importar cuál sea el punto mundial de
estas grandes potencias sin importar
también cuál sea la historia que nos
liga particularmente con eeuu
la crisis la caída de nuestros marcos de
cooperación las fragilidades que acabo
de evocar nos imponen reconstruir un
nuevo orden y le imponen a europa tomar
toda su parte de responsabilidad es
decir llevar sus valores su gusto por el
futuro y saber construir soluciones
nuevas porque no estamos colectivamente
condenados a una situación en la cual
nos veríamos reducidos a hacer solamente
espectadores de una impotencia colectiva
tenemos márgenes de maniobra tenemos que
saber utilizarlos nos corresponde saber
definir las prioridades que son las
nuestras en este paciente para poder
imponer con
para poder construir nuevas alianzas
tendremos que tomar decisiones ante
nuestros pueblos ante la comunidad
internacional y estas elecciones tendrán
un impacto inmediato sobre la vida de
las naciones sobre la existencia de los
ciudadanos sobre la marcha del mundo no
debemos dejarnos distraer porque cuando
es cuando las cosas están así que hay
querer volver a lo esencial y creo
profundamente que desde el principio de
esta crisis del coi 19 no es una
paréntesis la que se abre y se cierra
búsqueda de un mundo que atraviesa
crisis profundas que también se deben
gracias a nuestra interdependencia y
claramente llegar a un día pero no habrá
un milagro para el orden contemporáneo
no hay un remedio milagro para esta
situación nunca en nuestras situaciones
han sido tan interdependientes y en el
momento en que todo esto llega nunca
habíamos estado tan en desacuerdo tan
desalineados tan incapaces de construir
soluciones rápidas
en esta situación nosotros a veces a
punto de destruir los marcos de
compresión que nosotros mismos
construimos es por eso que quería decir
hasta ante esta asamblea las cinco
prioridades sobre las cuales francia
desea construir con sus socios europeos
pero también con todas las potencias de
buena voluntad es decir con todos
aquellos que están listos para
comprometerse para un nuevo consenso
contemporáneo que nos permita actuar en
el mundo tal y como es
el primer principio y el primer objetivo
es la lucha contra la proliferación de
armas de destrucción masiva y contra el
terror y nash que amenazan nuestra
seguridad colectiva y la estrategia de
la presión máxima desde hace ya varios
años tomadas no ha permitido poner fin a
las actividades de
estabilizadoras de grandes y de
asegurarnos que no pueda dotarse de un
arma nuclear
es por eso que francia como ustedes
recuerdan ya no es el país que inició la
negociación que llevó al acuerdo
pero francia con sus socios alemanes y
británicos mantendrá su exigencia de
mantener el acuerdo de viena de 2015 y
no aceptarán las vibraciones cometidas
por iran no estamos de acuerdo con la
activación de un mecanismo de eeuu que
tras haber salido de acuerdo quiere
reactivar sería atacar en el consejo de
seguridad la integridad de sus
decisiones sería tomar el riesgo de
agravar todavía más las regiones las
tensiones en los regionales pero tenemos
que construir un marco de acción útil
que en esta asamblea general
yo recordé hace de dos años es decir la
capacidad de completar el acuerdo de
2015 primero con el tiempo para asegurar
que
en el tiempo no tengan acceso al arma
nuclear sino también asegurándonos que
podamos traer respuestas a las
actividades balísticas de irán pero
también a sus desestabilizaciones
regionales sobre corea del norte
apoyamos los esfuerzos de eeuu para
permitir el compromiso de una
negociación incluso si los resultados
tangibles todavía no están allí estas
iniciativas son importantes y lo que
esperamos en este momento son gestos de
compromiso concretos por parte de corea
del norte debe conformarse a las
resoluciones del consejo de seguridad y
comprometerse rápidamente y de buena fe
en un proceso de desnuclearización
completa verificable e irreversible es
la única vía posible para lograr una
solución política para una paz duradera
en la península coreana
es necesario para la estabilidad
regional y para la seguridad
unap y como también para la paz y la
seguridad internacional
de misma forma no vamos a tolerar que
armas químicas sean utilizadas en europa
o en rusia en nombre de la seguridad
colectiva vuelvo a decirle aquí a rusia
la necesidad de que se esclarezca el
intento de asesinato contra un oponente
político con el nobel shop
esto debe ser rápido y sin defecto
porque haremos respetar esas líneas
rojas y francia
en este tema siempre ha estado ahí
cuando se trata de la efectividad de las
líneas rojas establecidas desde que soy
presidente de la nuestra seguridad
colectiva también es la lucha contra el
terrorismo en todas partes donde sea
necesario la fuerza y francia se ha
visto tocada
hace ya varios años de manera repetida
por el terrorismo en nuestro propio
territorio lo hemos vivido en carne
propia con actos terroristas comentados
en el epicentro mismo del terrorismo
islamista y pienso en los atentados de
2015 por supuesto y por afo es por eso
que francia siempre ha estado firmemente
comprometida para con el apoyo de la
soberanía iraquí y queremos
y estaremos en la coalición
internacional tuvimos una primera
victoria con el final del califato
territorial que no marca el fin de la
lucha continuaremos luchando en el sahel
en el marco de la coalición
internacional y junto a todos nuestros
socios regionales quiero aquí hacer un
llamado al rol colectivo de los kurdos
tuvieron en el combate de esta colisión
en contra de isis y también quiero
recordar el rol esencial que iraq y los
iraquíes tuvieron y siguen teniendo en
este combate ahora y es por eso que
francia apoya con fuerza todas las
iniciativas que irak está tomando hoy
continuará tomando para su soberanía y
su rol en la lucha contra el terrorismo
usted piensa en francia como ustedes
saben está profundamente comprometida al
lado de
cinco estados de la región y la cumbre
de popa permitió generar las bases para
la lucha en esta región de al qaeda y el
estado y también estas dos
organizaciones en los últimos meses han
tenido reveses sin precedentes los
objetivos fijados en popa se
concentraban en la zona de tres
fronteras y han generado resultados
tangibles
y vamos a continuar con este trabajo con
el apoyo de bacán y de los socios
estadounidenses del sahel las tropas han
tomado son las que habían sido perdidas
esta dinámica debe continuar es el
sentido mismo de la coalición que
estamos dirigiendo lo que acaba de
ocurrir en mali en las últimas semanas
nos recuerda también algo evidente la
democracia y la lucha contra el
terrorismo van de la mano
estos dos combates no son inseparables
son la democracia y la justicia en el
estado de derecho al desarrollo van a
traer una paz duradera al sahel
los que hicieron irrupción en el mal y
en nombre de sus principios no deben
ahora traicionar los deben poner a mali
en el camino hacia el retorno de un
poder civil y la organización de
elección direcciones rápidas francia
como sus socios africanos en
particularmente no podrá quedarse
comprometida solamente con esa condición
lo digo muy claramente francia solamente
está presente
no estaba presente en otros países
solamente por la petición de las
organizaciones regionales y en el
momento en que esos estados quieren que
nos vayamos o consideren que pueden
luchar solos contra terrorismo nos
retiraremos y ese entonces la
reiteración de esta demanda que es por
eso que le pedido en qué pedido en poo y
que esto fue reconfirmado en mali y es
sobre este tema que vamos a seguir
siendo vigilantes creo en la soberanía
de los pueblos y creo que nuestra acción
contra el terrorismo sólo puede ser útil
y durable si se conjuga con el respeto
de la soberanía con una democracia
efectiva y con una verdadera política de
desarrollo que es la que hemos concebido
con la alianza para el sahel y que con
nuestros socios europeos africanos y con
el banco mundial continuaremos
desarrollando para acciones útiles en el
terreno
y la segunda prioridad a mis ojos en los
próximos meses es la construcción
exigente de la paz y de la estabilidad
en el respeto de la soberanía de los
cuales estoy que redefinirlo porque las
líneas se han movido en favor de la
crisis
la salida o el retroceso de eeuu
la afirmación hegemónica de otras
grandes potencias en favor de esta falta
de compromiso la proyección de china más
allá de sus fronteras y la soberanía
europea
todo esto nos llevan a tener que
repensar nuestras acciones colectivas
para garantizar la paz y la seguridad a
nuestro principio de acción debe ser
claro
y nuestra mano no debe temblar en su
aplicación el respeto de los derechos
soberanos de los pueblos la
consolidación de los estados de derecho
y de sus medios de acción la exigencia y
la responsabilidad para asegurar la
puesta en marcha de las decisiones
bajo el régimen de la onu es exactamente
lo que hacemos en líbano donde las
aspiraciones del pueblo libanés soberano
deben ser respetadas escuchadas y
apoyadas
y quiero aquí volver a decir y expresar
mi apoyo por el pueblo libanés y mi
determinación para actuar desde donde yo
estoy en el respeto de la soberanía
libanesa pero también como una amistad
que exige para que el líbano pueda
levantarse para que la vida pueda
mejorar y para que también el camino de
una calma y de una democracia más
efectiva sea encontrado pero el líbano
es un tesoro para la humanidad entera un
tesoro porque es una forma de excepción
de democracia y de pluralismo en unas
regiones que ha sido tocada por el
terrorismo y las potencias hegemónicas
naciones unidas en concretamente deben
ser deben estar comprometidas con la
sociedad civil y de las ongs para hacer
enfrentar
las necesidades inmediatas y apoyar la
reconstrucción y aquí también apoyaremos
en síria la retomada de los diálogos en
general es una es algo positivo pero no
puede limitarse a una nueva constitución
tendrán que pasar por elecciones libres
y regulares y transparentes para
respetar también las aspiraciones y la
soberanía del pueblo sirio francia y sus
socios europeos continuarán entonces
condicionando el financiamiento de la
reconstrucción y de la normalización de
las relaciones con damasco a la puesta
en marcha de una solución política
creíble la única que sea durable la
única que va a permitir erradicar al
terrorismo en esa región de la paz en
medio oriente sigue siendo una necesidad
primero para los israelíes y para los
palestinos pero también para todos
y me alegra que esa gente haya recibido
reconocimiento de otros países árabes
que es una esperanza para el futuro pero
sin embargo una paz justa y duradera
necesita antes que todo encontrar los
medios de una negociación que le permita
a los palestinos tener finalmente sus
derechos no hay una alternativa a una
negociación llena de valentía que
necesita comprenderse sobre los temas
más difíciles en el respeto de los de
las aspiraciones al reconocimiento pleno
y total a la seguridad y a la soberanía
de todos
no creo en una paz que se construirá
bajo la hegemonía o la humillación
cuando ésta sea recompensada con dinero
porque bien sabemos que no se puede
compensar una la humillación de un
pueblo por dinero nos corresponde
colectivamente construir esta solución
ambiciosa
en libia la crisis ha tenido un impacto
en la estabilidad regional y se ha
multiplicado las injerencias externas
libia desde mis ojos la ilustración
perfecta de los errores a los cuales
solo podemos conducir nosotros mismos
cuando no respetamos la soberanía
nacional ninguna potencia puede
construir el bien de un pueblo cuando a
no ser que se haya construido a sí mismo
también no tenemos otra opción que
actuar de manera concreta es lo que hace
europa para hacer respetar de manera
efectiva por todos el embargo de armas
decidido por la onu y este embargo hoy
es violado por varias potencias y eso no
es algo durable y varias potencias
también han decidido continuar
importando combatientes desde siria
exportando el terrorismo a esta región
dándole la espalda a los intereses de
libia de sus vecinos del sahel y de
europa y colectivamente hemos sido muy
silenciosos sobre este tema y tenemos
que ser mucho más firmes en las próximas
semanas tenemos que trabajar con
nuestros socios en los países vecinos de
libia para obtener un cese al fuego
durable y generar una dinámica que pueda
permitir una resolución política del
conflicto bajo las opciones unidas es
una iniciativa que francia desea liderar
de la mano con el secretario general es
reunirse con todos los países vecinos
para ayudar a generar una solución en
libia un nuevo compromiso de los vecinos
de libia que es algo indispensable en el
mediterráneo oriental tenemos que
contribuir a un diálogo eficaz para
evitar un nuevo espacio de confrontación
y de que se ponga en tela de juicio el
derecho internacional los países del
mediterráneo de la unión europea se
expresaron claramente hace algunos días
en hay acción
tenemos que respetar a turquía estamos
listos a dialogar con turquía pero
esperamos que respete la soberanía
europea al derecho internacional y apoye
claridad sobre sus acciones en libia
como en siria también los insultos
son inoperantes y todas estas palabras
no tienen lugar en estas relaciones y el
llamado de la responsabilidad que europa
le lanzó a nosotros europeos estamos
listos para el diálogo para la
construcción y para la construcción de
un hábitat
baksi mediterránea y no bajo la lógica
del más fuerte sino en el respeto de la
cooperación y del respeto entre aliados
estos principios no son negociables en
europa continental sobre la crisis
ucraniana el formato de normandía nos
permitió este año junto a la canciller
merkel obtener los primeros avances y la
situación en bielorrusia tiene el riesgo
de una nueva fractura en el continente
el coraje del pueblo bielorruso merece
la realización de todos y sus
aspiraciones deben ser respetadas
nosotros estamos junto a ellos quiero
decirlo aquí con mucha fuerza un diálogo
político nacional debe establecerse y
toda intervención exterior
debe ser evitada
tuvimos la ocasión de junto a la
canciller alemana y el presidente del
consejo europeos intercambiar con el
presidente putin
y pedir para una mediación mi propuesta
no fue por la ucedé no vemos ningún otro
camino que es más yo no a la injerencia
y no al silencio culpable
europa aquí también estará presente con
sus responsabilidades de su historia y
de su geografía pero creer en la paz y
la estabilidad en la región también es
querer construirlo para la europa
continental
nuevas gramáticas de una estabilidad
durable y es
no puede reducirse a los acuerdos
históricos ni en el fondo al
desmantelamiento de dichos acuerdos en
los últimos años cuando hablamos de paz
y seguridad colectiva para europa no
puedo quedarme callado hoy ante el hecho
de que estamos viviendo una situación
para la seguridad estabilidad
y que dependería ampliamente de los
acuerdos firmados entre eeuu y américa
la unión soviética y estos acuerdos se
han ido desmantelando
en los últimos años como por ejemplo el
ing
que marca una etapa importante durante
la cual no podemos mantener el silencio
nosotros europeos tenemos que
comprometernos con un marco de una
discusión completa y ambiciosa con los
vecinos para nuestra propia seguridad
colectiva y construir un marco nuevo que
tenga en cuenta el fin de estos tratados
históricos y lo digo aquí también con
mucha claridad no vamos a delegar
nuestra seguridad a seguridad colectiva
a otras potencias que a la propia europa
tercero tenemos que proteger los bienes
que no son comunes
es nuestra responsabilidad ir más allá
de los intereses nacionales de los
equilibrios regionales proteger los
bienes comunes no es contradictorio con
el ejercicio de nuestra soberanía es al
contrario la única manera de preservar
la realmente manteniendo el control de
nuestro destino es exactamente lo que
esta crisis que estamos atravesando
demuestra de manera que no se puede
contestar
la salud de uno entre epidemias de la
salud de todos tenemos la ocasión de
crear maneras de lucha entre la ante la
pandemia para los que todos debemos
tener acceso es el sentido de la acción
que estamos llevando y que vamos a
consolidar en los próximos meses
sobre todo en lo que tiene que ver con
los sistemas de salud
y la salud que es un bien público
mundial es un combate que hemos llevado
a lo largo de todo el año y que también
lo habíamos mantenido en el guión que
cuando teníamos que movilizar la
comunidad internacional para financiar
la lucha contra
las epidemias históricas y es lo que
continuaremos haciendo y tenemos que
darle más fuerza en los próximos el
clima y la biodiversidad deben ser más
que nunca o estar en el centro de
nuestra agenda no con palabras sino con
actos el acuerdo de parís ya va a
anunciar cinco años y sabemos que los
objetivos que nos fijamos colectivamente
no van a ser alterados la respuesta a la
pandemia puede pronto no cambiar más los
planes masivos adoptados en todos los
países son una dimensión histórica para
una transformación de los modelos
económicos y de desarrollo y esto debe
estar en el corazón de la unión europea
y la presidenta de la comisión debe
estar en el centro de los trabajos del
g7 y el g20 es algo indispensable y es
por eso que también quiero que francia
el día del aniversario de los cinco años
del acuerdo de parís pueda movilizar de
nuevo a la conagua internacional con el
fin
de que cada uno de nosotros pueda mirar
dónde estamos con respecto a nuestros
compromisos sin cambiar la medida de las
cosas pero movilizando nuevamente el
conjunto de los países y las regiones en
una transparencia completa pero también
con una voluntad que hay que renovar y
europa en las próximas semanas va a
llegar a un acuerdo para lograr la
neutralidad de carbono para el año 2050
la presidenta de la comisión europea
puso este objetivo de reducción de las
emisiones de gases de efecto invernadero
en un 55 por ciento para el 2030 eso
significa ir más rápido más fuerte en un
tema ambicioso mítico un mecanismo de
inclusión de carbono en las fronteras
la mayoría de estas medidas significan
las unas y las otras no tendrían la
misma
con nuestros socios británicos y
europeos iremos a buscar esto uno por
uno los compromisos de las traen la cob
26 junto a los socios europeos y esto
será algo esencial en noviembre vamos a
reunir en parís a una cumbre de
desarrollo para asegurarnos que los
flujos financieros contribuyen a un re
lance de que vayan en línea con el
acuerdo de parís sobre la biodiversidad
con respecto al cambio climático y la
salud humana no solamente hay un lazo
nexo en los próximos meses vamos a
establecer la en marsella con el banco
mundial en una cumbre que va a permitir
crear una imagen manera de acción común
sobre la agroecología ayudar
financiación de la biodiversidad y la
lucha contra la deforestación la
protección también de los ecosistemas y
de las
visión los océanos los polos
los bosques tropicales son un patrimonio
común de la humanidad y tenemos que
protegerlo y lo haremos
ante estas cumbres decisivas que serán
esenciales en la lucha contra el cambio
climático para estar ahí les propongo
que una cumbre se ha organizado el
próximo año nueva york antes de este
estrés cop para darle un impulso
es necesario que lleve a resultados
tangibles el espacio digital también es
un espacio común único abierto y de
confianza que debe ser objeto de un
gobierno nuevo para evitar que sea
pirateado el instrumentalizado son las
iniciativas que llevamos en esta
sociedad de información y democracia
y también sobre la inteligencia
artificial y queremos consolidar cada
una de estas sociedades y avanzar en el
proceso agradezco a la primera ministra
de nueva zelanda estas son las
soluciones concretas que ahora tenemos
necesidad no solamente de compromisos
sino también de acciones de grandes
operadores acciones de las grandes
plataformas y de un compromiso de todos
para reglamentar a nivel de nuestras
regiones
si no cumplen con estos compromisos
adquiridos la lucha contra el terrorismo
el odio
la creación de un orden público común de
internet también son tan importantes que
la innovación y tecnológica que la
libertad porque no hay libertad sin
orden público nos corresponde crearlo a
través de un compromiso internacional y
no creo que la protección desde la
libertad de expresión
pueda acomodarse al discurso terrorista
y a los discursos de odio al anonimato
que cubre de alguna manera este al
lanzamiento de la violencia
esta agenda es esencial para todos y
continuaremos actuando con fuerza y
finalmente y lo digo en un contexto que
es el de la epidemia que acaba de
recordar la educación es un abismo que
también es esencial y sobre el cual
continuaremos comprometidos en el futuro
cientos de millones de los niños
quedaron por fuera de la educación y por
culpa de la epidemia pero sobre todo la
educación de las niñas debe ser una
prioridad principalmente en áfrica al
lado del presidente macky sall nos
comprometimos para diana sociedad
mundial para la educación y levantamos
nuevos fondos para poder financiar las
acciones de esta sociedad
los gurús el rol de la calidad de hoy
del banco mundial de las naciones unidas
de la sociedad mundial para la educación
de la unesco también las acciones
bilaterales deben ser reforzadas para
actuar de manera más eficaz en los años
a futuro para mejorar la educación y
sobre todo la educación de las niñas
pequeñas este combate no ha terminado y
no lo vamos a olvidar está en el corazón
y en el centro del compromiso francés en
materia de defensa y de lucha por los
bienes públicos
la cuarta prioridad es la construcción
de una nueva era de la mundialización la
primera era de la mundialización se
abrió por los viajes de cristóbal colón
el descubrimiento de las primeras
invasiones también de una cierta forma
de fascinación a veces de malentendido
recíproco
la segunda fue la de los imperios
coloniales y de la revolución industrial
del siglo 19 fue la mundialización a
través del comercio las primeras
aperturas pero también
las rutas de la esclavitud de la
explotación del desarrollo de uno de los
primeros desplazamientos poblacionales y
la recomposición del mundo con estas
nominaciones con la tercera comenzó en
1984 con la caída del 89 con la caída
del muro de berlín
permitiendo la circulación de personas y
después pues entiendo que la internet
generará convergencias de ideas y de
valores en el fondo es en esta era de la
mundialización y que aquí podríamos
separar cada uno de estos de estas eras
en otros periodos por supuesto pero es
esta era en la que quedó en tela de
juicio y en duda desde hace unos diez
años porque la condición profunda que la
acompañaba era que esta mundialización
sería una mundialización de la paz un
acercamiento de valores una
universalización del respeto al otro y
quedó en duda por la crisis financiera
por las transformaciones mundiales y por
el regreso de los pueblos de las
conciencias nacionalistas
y finalmente por la pandemia también
quedó en duda por una crisis profunda de
las clases medias
occidente de occidentales que en algún
momento dudaron que este nuevo orden
porque esta nueva mundialización podría
traerles a estas clases medias que en
todas partes del occidente fueron
variables de ajustes económicos y
culturales de este mundo tan abierto
entonces que sería no tendría
fundamentos negar lo que todo este
periodo ha permitido en materia de
avances lo que esta tercera era de la
mundialización permitió aportar en
términos de productividad
y la salida de cientos de millones de
personas de la pobreza profunda con una
redistribución del comercio de la
producción
y también la apertura generó una
apertura de conciencia y de circulación
que han pacificado en cierto modo las
relaciones y sería peligroso encerrarlos
en un proteccionismo generalizado con
guerras comerciales en una especie de
duda que nos llevaría al encierro oa la
lógica de las potencias porque lo vemos
bien el riesgo es responder a esta
crisis de la mundialización con un
retroceso nacionalista con la violencia
de los extremos y los populismos y con
el regreso de las potencias pero es
claro que las cadenas de valor mundiales
hoy deben ser repensadas porque la
crisis demostró que la dependencia de
los sectores estratégicos como la salud
lo digital la inteligencia artificial la
alimentación también pueden poner en
cuestión el ejercicio libre de la
soberanía pero tenemos que ver también
que hay dependencias buenas y hay
dependencias que nos hacen más frágiles
tenemos que mantener el comercio
internacional y la apertura porque es
bueno para nosotros en el plano
económico eso sí también social porque
no podríamos hacer todo solos porque
generan dependencias que crean
cooperación
pero la dependencia completa con
respecto a ciertas potencias ya sea
tecnológica alimentaria o industrial
crea vulnerabilidades que crean
desequilibrios que cambian el orden
mundial y entonces las desigualdades
de este nuevo orden mundial ya no son
sostenibles sacamos a cientos de
millones de personas de la pobreza
extrema en los países reduce redujimos
minustah nunca estas inequidades pero
las creamos aún más y las profundizamos
en nuestros propios países y esto hace
que sea democráticamente insostenible lo
que está ocurriendo hemos creado una
mundialización de las conciencias que
hoy es una mundialización no del saber
que era el tema del internet sino una
mundialización y más que fue de la
emoción y del resentimiento
en cada una de estas crisis tenemos que
aportar lo que sabemos es esta
estrategia en la unión europea de la
cual nos estamos dotando con otras
potencias donde es imperativo que las
reglas internacionales sean adaptadas
para tener en cuenta estas nuevas
realidades y dotarnos de una realidad
internacional que sea más equilibrada y
que nos permita actuar en la soberanía
para el beneficio de todos en este tema
la lucha contra la inequidad debe ser
claramente y estar en el centro de esta
nueva mundialización presencia va a
permitir iniciativas para la iniciativa
femenina para la educación para la salud
para todos para luchar contra las
inequidades pero habrá que ir más allá
de alguna forma ustedes lo ven en este
mundo en el cual hemos vivido cosas que
se reposa sobre un consenso académico
que éste se traduce en un consenso
político que se llama el del consenso de
washington ya terminó y tenemos que
repensar las bases de una mundialización
más justa más equilibrada más
tenemos que repensar los términos de una
mundialización que acepte repensar los
términos de una soberanía justa y de un
intercambio justo que integre en su seno
la lucha contra la inequidad en todas
sus formas que sea de género de
condiciones económicas en la lucha
contra el calentamiento global y por la
biodiversidad y que permita de manera
durable integrar las condiciones de un
nuevo equilibrio mundial y aquí
tendremos nuevas propuestas en el foro
de parís y en el trabajo yo he iniciado
con la comisión europea con el fondo
internacional y con otras potencias de
una voluntad que también será esencial
para este objetivo aplicar será también
el motor para esta redefinición de la
mundialización y por eso sentí veremos
nuestros esfuerzos en el marco de una
iniciativa que hemos construido para
ayudar a los países africanos a
enfrentar la pandemia en términos
económicos humanitarios y sanitarios en
el g20 de noviembre
será una cumbre decisiva para la
moratoria de la deuda que hemos pactado
y para ir aún más allá también tenemos
que acompañar mejor las inmensas
decepciones díaz de la juventud del
continente que es la fuerza y su futuro
desde el sentido de las iniciativas que
traeremos en los próximos meses con
lluvias fuera y con el apoyo al sector
privado africano
y el quinto objetivo
así que voy a tratar de proponer colitis
es otro colectivo es el respeto del
derecho internacional humanitario y de
los derechos fundamentales de cada uno
para mí este objetivo es algo esencial a
la jimena para la supervivencia misma
de nuestra organización no sé si
asistimos aquí a unos retrocesos y a
veces a demasiados líderes desde la
creación de una jornada mundial
humanitaria 5.000 trabajadores han sido
víctimas de ataques 1.800 aficionados
haití el año pasado fue el más mortífero
y pienso particularmente
en estos jóvenes franceses y francesas
que deberían actuar directamente en este
marco en nigeria y que fueron asesinados
en condiciones atroces naciones unidas
no puede quedarse inactiva ante una tal
regresión es por eso que con las ongs
francesas con nuestros socios
internacionales vamos a construir una
iniciativa para asegurar la efectividad
del derecho internacional la protección
del personal humanitario y la lucha
contra la impunidad y el espacio
humanitario es un patrimonio común que
tenemos que proteger garantizando el
acceso a las poblaciones civiles como la
protección desde los personales que los
protegen hemos visto retrocesos en estos
temas que son inexcusables de prácticas
incluso de por parte de miembros del
consejo de seguridad en siria
particularmente que son inaceptables la
neutralidad de la acción humanitaria
debe ser respetada y su criminalización
indica
tomar nuestras responsabilidades en el
tema humanitario también es hacer prueba
de solidaridad de idiomas
en términos migratorios la situación en
grecia en murias es muy difícil francia
al lado de alemania y de sus socios
tomarán sus responsabilidades para
acoger refugiados y tenemos que actuar
todos juntos en la gestión de los flujos
migratorios para poner fin al tráfico
humano a las travesías de la muerte y
las rutas de necesidades eso estará en
el centro de la agenda europea de las
próximas semanas y podría hablar al
respecto después tendremos que
intensificar la lucha contra los
traficantes y estar ahí en la cita ante
las responsabilidades finalmente los
derechos fundamentales no son una idea
occidental que podríamos imponer como
una injerencia son principios de nuestra
organización que están inscritos en
textos que los estados miembros de la
onu firmaron y que se comprometieron a
respetar es la razón por la cual francia
pidió que una misión internacional bajo
ojos de la onu pueda ir a xinjiang
tomar en cuenta las preocupaciones que
colectivamente hemos despertado ante la
minoría musulmana uigur y es por eso que
no podemos tolerar que el 25 años
después de la conferencia de pekín los
derechos de las mujeres en el mundo
vayan en retroceso
es por eso que organizaremos un foro de
igualdad con la sociedad civil para la
emancipación de todas la educación de
las niñas y el respeto real y efectivo
de los derechos
estos son los cinco principios sobre los
cuales francia quiere reconstruirla con
ustedes las bases del orden
internacional para que las bases no sean
llevadas por la pandemia al contrario
tenemos que tomar el camino de la mano
antes de que nos tome por el cuello
se necesita esto necesita métodos y la
cooperación de una comunidad
internacional basada en reglas claras
definidas y respetadas por todos el
multilateralismo es un acto de fe
hay una necesidad operacional ningún
país va a salir solo de la cooperación
internacional será difícil pero es
objetivamente imperativo y no podemos
contentarnos de un multilateralismo de
palabras que permita decir que el
denominador común puede enmascarar
diferencias profundas hay que cambiar de
método cambiar los términos del contrato
y ser claros cuando algunos quieren
dicen que se adhieren a principios para
respetarlos
lúcidos y tenemos que exigir el
multilateralismo con separan yo también
debe venir asociado de las
organizaciones internacionales de los
actores privados de las empresas de las
ong de los ciudadanos de los
investigadores para que cada uno sea
parte de estas acciones más sonadas de
consolidar acuerdos sólidos verificados
alrededor de reglas claras que sean
verificables a través de mecanismos
establecido en el foro de país de parís
para la paz de noviembre con nuestros
africanos todos los que quieran en asia
en áfrica y en otras partes
consolidaremos las bases de este nuevo
consenso internacional al beneficio del
futuro de la organización
no creo que en un gran día de
refundación creo en un trabajo
determinado metódico riguroso de
reconstrucción de un orden internacional
contemporáneo que te permitirá llevar a
las futuras generaciones de alejarlas
del flagelo de la guerra afirmar los
derechos del hombre y la igualdad y
favorecer el progreso social es el la
promesa básica de nuestra carta creo en
la fuerza y en el valor de la sinceridad
y del coraje y y hablándoles en este
momento a pesar de la distancia que
crean estas pantallas tengo en memoria
la mirada de una niña libanesa con la
que me encontré hace unos días que había
perdido todo todo
pero que había jurado en luchar
por todo lo que ella cree
es la misma memoria por los jóvenes
asesinados en níger porque creían en un
mundo de fraternidad y de hermandad es
el mismo recuerdo que usted es
claramente deben tener lo que nos obliga
a lo que nos obliga a actuar y lo que
nos prohíbe el cinismo lo que nos obliga
a actuar y lo que nos lo que impide que
caigamos en facilismos
hay niños y niñas jóvenes en todas
partes del mundo que se comprometen con
algo porque creen en nuestras palabras
porque viven por y para nuestros
principios
si los traicionamos somos los primeros
culpables de su desilusión o derecho de
que pierdan todo nos corresponde hacer
lo que hace que somos capaces
y aquí donde estamos aquí haremos todo
para actuar y sé que con like muchos
colegas también están listos con el
cuento con ellos sacamos con cada uno de
ustedes gracias